you
hello and welcome to another course in
native language six lessons for language
learners this time around we're going to
look at how languages change over time
as well as how they're related to each
other there's something on the order of
6,000 languages spoken around the world
depending on how exactly we would define
and count individual languages that
brings up a really good question how
would we define language how would we
define individual human languages that's
actually a tough definition to give
here's one possible scenario let's say
that we have a speaker person one who
comes into contact with another speaker
person two and speaker one is able to
speak to person two and be understood by
person two and the same goes in Reverse
person two is able to speak with and be
understood by person one in that case we
have grounds for establishing mutual
intelligibility in other words the two
people can speak with and understand
each other and this is potentially
something we might call a language they
share a common language now they also
share a common language with the speaker
3 if person 3 comes meet speakers one
and two and is able to speak with and be
understood by both all three of these
people share a common language there's
mutual intelligibility
now what if speakers one two and three
visit a new area a new region where they
can understand the people and be
understood by the people in this new
region but the speech differs somewhat
the speech of the people in this new
region differs from the speech of
speakers one two and three in some
notable way well we would say that
speakers one two and three and the
speakers in this new region have
differing dialects but the speech of
these different speakers doesn't just
vary depending on the region it also
varies depending on the social situation
so we might find that all of these
people speakers one two and three use a
different form of their language when
they're speaking at home or at
work or in an official capacity with say
a government representative in all of
these cases we find different registers
in other words different social forms of
the language there's also room for
individual speech patterns and this
would define an idio lect this is on the
personal individual level in all of
these instances speakers still share
mutual intelligibility and a common
language so there's something like 6,000
of these languages spoken around the
world these languages don't differ from
each other at random
instead some languages are related to
some other languages and unrelated to
other languages it works a lot like
genetic relationships like family trees
during the rest of this course will
consider methods for comparing any two
languages or multiple languages and
seeing how closely they're related to
each other as well as how to look back
in time to extend that relationship into
the past and consider how we would
determine or even reconstruct the parent
or ultimate ancestor language so I hope
you'll stick with me as we work through
these next three lessons learning how to
use the historical comparative method to
look back in time into individual
languages and language relatedness